[Musique]
après avoir été toute leur vie les plus
célèbres ennemis du monde tom et jerry
sont sur le point de prendre à nouveau
départ dans la grande ville
[Musique]
le lot
cet hôtel a accueilli quatre présidents
trois papes de roi et bientôt nous
accueillerons le mariage du siècle
vous pensez être qualifié pour occuper
ce poste gévry quand je suis sous
pression comme un diamant ou comme
rihanna autre chose nous avons un
problème de souris je vous demande
pardon je vais la capturer
[Musique]
howe tous ces petits détails
nous pouvons appeler un dératiseur ou
exploiter l'héritage de millions
d'années d'évolution de grands
prédateurs la torpeur
si une photo de cette souris et
d'instabilité ou book fessée août et à
stocker nous seront ruinés non monsieur
ça n'arrivera pas ce rongeur étui
[Musique]
je n'accepterai pas que cet hôtel soit
détruite par un chat et une solide
il joue avec nos nerfs
je crois que ce n'est pas trop mal
réussi
[Musique]
à